have you been to america lately a lot of
americans really haven't
for months most of us have stayed close
to home we've had to
so the next time you get on a plane and
visit a couple of american cities
you may be surprised especially if you
remember those cities well from before
the pandemic
an awful lot has changed in a short time
many stores and restaurants are closed
you expect that
churches are locked on sunday morning
that's weird the streets seem empty
except for the parks which are full of
the homeless
when you do see people they tend to be
wearing masks and they won't get close
to you
it's a very strange experience the
country has changed a lot the culture
has changed a lot and really not for the
better
so the question is how long will this
last how long do we have to endure this
when do we get our country
back when can we live like we used to
live back in
february that question is too rarely
asked and in fact
asking it is actively discouraged at
first you'll remember the authorities
told us we could resume our lives when
hospital admissions tapered off and we
flattened the curve
the curve stayed flat in most places it
never bent
so we got a new benchmark for when we
can get back to normal when we get a
vaccine
everything will be fine once we can
vaccinate against covid19 many an
authority
told us that they're still telling us
that the state of virginia has announced
that when a vaccine finally does arrive
it will be mandatory not all vaccines
virginia will not require vaccines for
hepatitis or hiv
they won't require a vaccine for
meningitis either to fight despite the
fact that meningitis kills a lot more
say college students than chronovirus
does
but once we get a corona vaccine they're
telling us all will be well
now they've changed that not true
anymore
according to a new announcement from the
world health organization a vaccine
even if we get one will not be the end
of all of this
it will never end you can get your
injection they'll make you get it
but you'll still be under arrest the
world health organization says that
finding a vaccine is not the goal
reordering society is the goal
quote we will not we cannot go back to
the way
things were that's a direct quote from
the leader of the world health
organization
dr tedros who by the way is not really a
doctor
because covet 19 is not a public health
crisis really or even a mere virus
according to ted rose
in fact this may surprise you covet 19
is really
about global warming as he puts it quote
the covet 19 pandemic has given new
impetus to the need to accelerate
efforts to respond
to climate change i bet she didn't see
that coming
bill gates did he agrees that
wholeheartedly earlier this month gates
posted an essay to his personal website
which you probably haven't seen
arguing that the lesson of the corona
pandemic
is that the rest of us will have to
sacrifice even more
to save the earth from warming now for
people who are not
billionaire global influencers this is
all pretty confusing
quick what does the coronavirus have to
do with climate change
well for one thing china caused both of
them that's the obvious link
but that is definitely not the point dr
tedros and bill gates are making both of
them bow before china they would never
meaningfully criticize the chinese
government so you can be assured
that's not the connection they're
drawing no for dr tedros and bill gates
pandemic and climate change share a very
different connection
both are useful pretexts for mass social
control
both are essentially unsolvable crises
they can harness to bypass democracy
and force powerless populations to obey
their commands
now it makes sense ever wondered why our
leaders consider the coronavirus a major
public health crisis but not
say suicides and drug ods well this is
why
when a 26 year old mother in new
hampshire drops dead from fentanyl bill
gates and dr tedros don't get more
powerful
her death is useless to them so they
don't care
if you actually wanted to improve
people's lives you would look at things
very differently and you would probably
reach very different conclusions about
the pandemic
in just a few weeks a deadly virus
spread from central china
through europe to every major city in
the west
and as that happened the world health
organization did nothing to stop it and
in fact spread disinformation as it was
happening
those are the facts so what would a
rational person conclude
from those facts well the first and most
obvious lesson is globalization has
risks it has upsides
of course cheaper plastic crap from
china but it also has risks
pandemics spread very very fast
then as it happened our most important
international public health organization
failed on purpose it's corrupt the who
is corrupt that's a huge problem that's
the other lesson
but no one's learning those lessons when
was the last time you heard bill gates
or dr
tedros say those things never they never
will say them because they wouldn't
benefit from acknowledging
they're true this is true about all
crises
they only take the lessons that empower
them
how about global warming how would a
rational person
assess global warming if you really
believe that carbon emissions were
distorting the earth's climate and
that's the claim they make maybe they're
right
then you would take a very close look at
the forces behind
those carbon emissions you would ask
hard questions about the global economy
you'd wonder
who's profiting from this system that's
destroying the earth
how exactly do the riches most powerful
people in the world that would be big
finance in the tech monopolies
contribute to carbon emissions that
would be the first question you would
ask that's the logical way to think
about climate change
and if you began to think that way you
might wind up concluding that people
like i don't know
michael bloomberg were in fact climate
criminals
their private jets alone produce more
carbon emissions a year than entire
african villages do not to mention more
than your neighborhood does a lot more
but tellingly no one on the
environmental left
ever criticizes michael bloomberg he's
considered a leader in the fight against
climate change
on the basis of the numbers that is
ludicrous but they say with a straight
face and demand you believe it
part of this is human nature all of us
tend to place ourselves at the center
in the heroic center of our own
narratives that's particularly true of
rich people
who tend toward the narcissistic but in
this case
they are evading responsibility they are
profiting directly from a system they
claim is unacceptable but it's not their
fault somehow you know whose fault it is
oh it's your fault
you're the one who's doing it you're the
one who's killing humanity you're the
one who must change you've got too many
kids
you drive a pickup truck you forgot to
wear your little mask you're going to
hell
good luck with your bankruptcies and
your opioid crisis and your broken lives
middle america will be at the
yellowstone club having a drink
it's a scam it's an obvious scam
here's another data point for you that
you won't see on television less than a
month ago on july 31st the cdc
centers for disease control in atlanta
our primary public health organization
funded by the federal government
released guidelines to state health
departments about patients infected with
the chronovirus how do you track the
spread of this disease
in a footnote in the release the cdc
acknowledged that researchers lack
evidence that quote
masks offer any protection against
coronavirus any
at all as health officials work to track
the spread of the virus the cdc
suggested that they ignore
whether or not people were wearing masks
in other words
wearing a mask may be completely
irrelevant to the spread of the virus
huh so there is still no proof that
masks protect
us against covid19 that is apparently
the conclusion the cdc reached it's not
something trump tweeted
the cdc put that in a release to the
states it seems like a blockbuster story
why isn't that on page one of the new
york times
why is the entire media the entire
leadership class of the united states of
america ignoring this
mass are obligatory they're mandatory
everywhere
just the other day joe biden announced
that if he's elected you'll be required
to wear a mask when you're alone
outside what is going on
you know what's going on fear works
the more afraid you are the more you
will accept again a feature of human
nature the more cut off you are from
your family and your friends
the more power they have to control you
this is an election year democrats want
to win in november the virus is their
main shot to win
nobody disputes that who's looked at the
numbers they're using fear of the
chronovirus to achieve that
for example polling places they would
like to close more of them why to
force a vote by mail why because vote by
mail is more easy
to manipulate the latest coronavirus
relief bill the democrats are pushing
would bring ballot harvesting to every
state what does that have to do with
defeating the virus nothing
it's not science it's politics but
here's the key thing to remember
all of us are assuming and on the right
it is gospel
this will end if joe biden wins on
inauguration day no more lockdowns yet
don't bet on it this is an ending the
wuhan pandemic
has made our leadership class more
powerful than they had have
ever been why would they relinquish that
the only politician in america who has
ever given up power voluntarily
is george washington and they're
toppling his statues